to the tour de france now and british
cyclist mark cavendish has won
four stages of this year's race equaling
eddie merks's record of 34
tall stage victories and he joins
me now mark cavendish thank you very
much for being with us
we are talking to you uh on a rare rest
day but i wonder how much you are
able to rest ahead of the the next three
days of pyrenees mountain stages
yeah we still we went for a little ride
today and then it was kind of spending
stuff
doing doing media and that but i guess
if you do media means you've been
successful and with the
quick step we'd have we've had a
successful couple of weeks
we'll see five stage wins i got four
sprints there and
so we're half people yeah it's it's not
going to be easy to get to paris three
more days in the pyrenees like you said
and uh we'll just have to see how we go
how much of your success at mark is
down to that team that you have around
you
uh like cycling's a strange sport in the
uh
only one guy can cross the finish line
or or or one lady and but
there's a whole team behind it um
whereas like with the football you know
striker can score goal the whole team
wins at the end of the day
cycling is like that but only one guy
stands on the podium and uh
and so that's why it's extra special if
you have a group around you that
that delivery they have to deliver you
to that to that moment they have to
protect you through the mountains and uh
and a lot of the time for for no credit
no praise it's it's incredibly important
and uh
i'm thankful in the kind of quicksilver
i've got yeah the best team in the world
for that
yeah and we're talking about the
football a lot today of course and
debating the issues of youth versus
experience you're 36 now one of the
older riders on the tour but i wonder
how much that experience
plays a part and and gives you an edge
when things get tough
thanks for reminding me my age don't
worry i'm older
it's uh yeah honestly i think especially
in sprinting experiences
it plays quite a part you know you learn
how to read a race there's a lot going
on in a spring finish
there's we've got 170 bike riders all
going for the same thing
the same spot on the road the same
finish line you have to
try and be the one that gets there and
for sure you need the legs but um
knowing how a race is going to go and
it's quite tactical like cycling can
it can almost sometimes seem a bit
boring on tv but there's a lot going on
there's a lot of intricacies going on
and once you know a little bit it kind
of snowballs and
and you learn more and more and and uh
to see the things happening in in split
seconds it's uh
it definitely helps if you know what's
going on
just one final thought from you today
pagacha said that he grew up watching
you
as a kid you were his inspiration how
much are you aware of that what what
image do you want to project to young
children who are interested in cycling
i spoke to him the other day and he was
seven when i won my first
tour de france stage and it's crazy but
look i've seen
during since i started riding the tour
de france um all those years ago 13
years ago since i won
i've seen massive growth in cycling in
in the uk that's not just in people
racing by so people
doing it to keep fit and commuting
families going out and enjoying
themselves and
honestly that's been the proudest thing
of of my career is to see that growth in
cycling during that and uh
if we can if you know if we can be
successful
if if if me being successful can inspire
just one more person to get on a bike
um that's worth more than any medal for
me you know
job done yeah and mark we are running
out of time thank you very much
and the very best of luck